- That's right, it's our
Barbie Dream Hour, everybody.
I am Dark Diva Barbie, you're welcome.
And what would it be
without the cast of the huge, enormous,
upcoming blockbuster movie "Barbie"?
The movie opens in theaters
everywhere, July 21st.
Everybody, please give it up
for Margot Robbie,
(engine revving)
Issa Rae, Kate McKinnon, America Ferrera.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(Kate screaming)
(Kelly murmuring)
I'm so excited you're here.
We even dressed alike, too.
(audience applauding and cheering)
(guests murmuring)
Give it up, have a seat, ladies.
Oh my gosh, that was
the best entrance ever.
- I felt like I was selling
a car on a game show.
- Yeah, you were like, did you-
- I was like-
- Vanna White.
Yes, it was nice.
Her leg was over the
door, it was very classy.
Well, welcome back to Margot.
America, y'all been on this show before.
But welcome to the show, ladies.
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- It's such an incredible cast
of women, and men as well.
But last time you were here, you said...
Kind of, they're all right.
But you said you were gonna learn,
I think it was French and banjo.
Have you started at all?
- No, Kelly, it's been a
busy year and my New Year's-
- [Kelly] I've been
learning Spanish for 20, so.
- My New Year's resolutions
got pushed aside
and I'm still looking for a banjo teacher.
Remember we spoke about that.
- Margot, I'm ready for ya!
- Jaco could teach you.
He just is busy a lot.
His boss is crazy.
(audience applauding)
But your mom, Issa, was a teacher, right?
- Yeah, my mom was a French teacher
so she could help you with the
New Year's resolution, yeah.
- [Kelly] Look!
- [Margot] My resolutions
are back on track now.
- I got you, she got you.
I volunteer her.
- Her mom, Jaco,
between that, you have got this covered.
- No excuses anymore.
- But no, I love that
your mom was a teacher.
My mother was a teacher as well.
Did you ever feel like you
would go in that field at all?
Me, no.
- Yeah, no, I think, yes, seeing her-
- I like my kids, not y'all's (chuckles).
- It was just too much
and then, even watching...
We used to do "Take Your
Daughter To Work Day."
I used to visit her and that was fun.
But, kids are terrible, so I don't...
Thank God, she didn't teach at my school,
she taught at my younger siblings' school.
And so, they had it way worse.
So I had a healthy distance from it.
- (chuckles) That's amazing.
Yeah, I don't think my mom
taught at mine, ever, either.
We have loved you like on
SNL, everything you do.
- What?
(audience laughing)
- I have literally seen you
so much in my household.
Because Melissa lives next door to me
and your "Ghostbusters"
is my son's favorite.
I've seen it a billion times.
I feel like we're friends, it's awkward.
But, anyway, I love you-
- I'm a lifelong fan.
I am actually, a lifelong fan.
This is big.
(Kelly chuckling)
This is really big for me, you guys.
- No, so, I'm just a huge fan.
- I'm flustered.
- I'm wondering though,
'cause you're so funny
and I wonder with people
that are on SNL, did you grow up
in a hysterical family? Was
everybody funny in your family?
Did you grow up watching a lot of comedy?
- Hysterical, sure.
- How are you this funny?
- Yeah, my parents
actually, are very funny
and they used to quote SNL all the time.
Like, "We are from France," and, "Oh, no,"
and all these early SNL quotes
that I just thought were English phrases.
And so, I would say to my
teacher, "We are from France."
And she would be like, "Are you well?"
Or you know, that kind of thing.
(everyone laughing)
So, it was very much in
the culture of the home.
- I love that, what a
great home, that's fun.
- I was awesome.
- Were they freaking out
when you made it onto SNL?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I was gonna say they probably-
- Not as much as me.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- 'Cause then, I had to be
on SNL and I was scared.
- It's hysterical.
Well do people still come up
to you and ask for any kind of impression?
- They do.
I was asked recently,
"When are you gonna do
Justin Bieber again?"
And I was like, "It's not funny anymore.
He's a consummate professional.
He's a man of God with
a healthy marriage."
- He got (beep) together (chuckles).
- Yeah.
- That's hysterical.
- My favorite character is the one
that I actually got to
do the sketch with you
when you're playing the
oldest starlet with the-
- Oh, yeah, you were sweet
to participate in that.
- [Margot] That's like one
of my favorite characters
you've ever done.
And I got to see it firsthand.
- Oh, man!
- It's so funny.
- That's nice, she's...
(audience applauding)
- So America, did you know any
of these women before filming?
- No, I didn't know Margot at all.
Issa, maybe we said hi at events.
- We were on a whole panel
together, America, it's fine.
(everyone laughing)
I wasn't memorable or
anything, that's fine.
(Kelly laughing)
- That was qualifies as an event, Issa!
- That is like a real
friend that calls you out.
- The one in Boston?
The one we-
- So, now you know the-
- No, I do remember but that, okay, yeah.
See, okay, but there's-
- She's like, "Wrong
answer, I knew everyone."
- But this is my problem
because actually, my story about Kate is
that I saw her at an event
and I thought, "Oh, my god,
that's Kate McKinnon,
I have to go say hi."
And I walked up
and I was like, "Kate,
I am your biggest fan."
And she's like, "America,
you don't remember?"
And I was like, "Oh no, what?"
But you went by a different last name.
- Sure.
- And when we were
in high school, we both both attended
the same drama summer program
at Northwestern University.
And it was like one of those moments
in the movie where your
mind rewinds quickly
and forward and then things make sense.
And I go, "You're Kate, you're funny Kate.
You're the funniest person
that was at the camp
and also, the funniest person
I'd ever met to that date,
and of course, you're Kate McKinnon!"
- But I remember it
'cause America was in...
We all had our separate shows, right?
And America did the most
amazing dramatic monologue
and everyone was like,
(groans), "America."
And I was like, "Oh my God, America."
And I played a bug in my show.
(everyone laughing)
And so-
- But it was the funniest bug ever.
- [Kate] It's okay that
you didn't remember me.
- I'm just gonna not be offended
when I see America tomorrow
or something and she's
like, "And you are?"
- But as a joke, I-
- It's okay,
you forget everyone, it's okay.
- As a joke, I should've been
like, "Welcome to the show,
you've never been here."
- The truth is last night, I tried
to envision what this was gonna feel like.
And I thought, "If little America knew
that she was standing or sitting next
to these four people
who I truly, deeply,
deeply admire and idolize,"
I was crying
in bed last night thinking
about this moment.
- [Kate] Aww, that's nice.
- So this is like a dream and this is-
- It's a dream cast for sure.
- This is what making the movie felt like,
it was like how...
It's a dream.
- I love that.
So Margot, is it true
that you had a sleepover
for the cast, before the movie?
- We had a Barbie sleepover.
It was as fun as it sounds.
It was Greta's idea.
- You're welcome, cast.
- Yeah, it was Greta's
idea, I can't take credit.
We all went to Claridge's
which is a really
gorgeous hotel in London.
We all shared beds and wore our pajamas
and ordered room service and played games
and found out that America
is exceptionally competitive.
(everyone laughing)
- I am extremely competitive
and nobody told me
that it was a sexy Barbie sleepover.
So everybody was in really
pretty, silky nightgowns.
And I was
in the most grandma, floral,
twin set you could imagine.
- She somehow simultaneously,
looked like an old lady
but a five-year-old at the
same time, it was the cutest.
And she's so teeny-
- While she's yelling
at you during the game?
- While she's screaming at
you, but it was so charming.
I mean she was like
the cutest little thing
you'd put a toddler in and go to bed
and then she was rousing at us
for not knowing the rules, so it was-
- If they're not gonna play-
- If you're not gonna
compete, why are you here?
- If you're not gonna do it.
- Why play?
Margot, another of your
Kens was Ryan Gosling.
So what was it like to work
with him? He's so talented.
- Again, as amazing as it
sounds, he is just, woo!
- [Kelly] He's funny, man.
He's got very funny, comedic timings.
- He is the most comedically gifted actor.
I think he's just so known as being
such a brilliant dramatic actor
that people are sometimes
like, "Oh yeah, he is really funny.
He was funny in that thing."
In this movie, he's funny on
a completely different level.
I ruined all his takes
'cause I just laughed through them.
I actually, now watch the edit of the film
and I can see Greta cutting away
before I laugh and my
corners of my mouth are like,
and then she cuts back to him
'cause I've started laughing.
- 'Cause he's so serious,
but it's so funny.
- 'Cause he's so funny.
- Oh, and I agree.
- He's going for it
in this movie, it's amazing.
- Issa, Margot, so you guys,
y'all have a dance scene
in the movie?
How was that?
It was so good, I saw it, actually.
- Yeah, was it?
(audience laughing)
- You're amazing!
- You know, it was my first day.
The dance sequence happened my first day,
it was like I landed.
They told me that it was gonna
be a dance sequence in it.
And I was like, "Oh, cool, that
has nothing to do with me."
And then, they sent me the
footage to rehearse it.
I had something that I was doing in D.C.
and I had to learn it in 24 hours,
and the cast had been
already working on it.
And so I was like, "This is
literally my worst nightmare.
I'm not a dancer."
So I tried to learn the routine,
I was with my friends.
They were like, "Girl, get
it, one, two, one, two.
Get it, one, two, three, four."
And then when I landed, they were
like, "Oh, the dance is
completely different," (laughs).
So then I landed,
my first day meeting the cast
was doing this dance number
and it was-
- What a way to break the ice.
- Yeah, way to break the ice
in my face, yes, my pride,
my ego but, you know.
- I'm bummed you didn't get
to do the dance rehearsals
with us 'cause that was
honestly the funnest part
of prepping this movie is doing...
We do dance rehearsals
for probably two weeks.
This, definitely, was
why it was so stressful
for you 'cause you
didn't get the two weeks.
But we'd all go and I'd been doing it
for a week on my own,
and I was like, "Ooh, this is so fun,"
'cause it's like the kinda dancing you do
with a hairbrush in front of your mirror
when you're a kid, so it's
like silly, fun, dancing.
But, then the other Barbies
all started arriving
for the dance rehearsal
and then I was like...
My ego went through the roof
'cause they're like, "Yeah!"
Everyone's screaming and clapping
and then, we'd do it all together.
And then we'd get everyone
before shooting, we'd get
out whole crew and everything
to do a little dance warmup together.
And it was so fun,
just the vibe the rest of the
day would be, just amazing.
- Well, I don't know if you know
but, Drew, I mean, you guys rehearse too.
I know that y'all dance. I
know that you can dance it out.
You wanna show some moves?
Were you wanting to show
us some moves, guys?
Why you backing up?
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Are you doing Kid 'n Play?
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Oh my God.
My favorite part was your restart.
You were like, "No, we didn't get it."
- From the top, a one, two, three, four.
- From the top.
You can tell the year you
were born by that dance alone.
It was the same year as me (chuckles).
- [Margot] That was impressive-
- We have an impressive crew, 11 Emmys.
They got nominated, 11 Emmys.
(everyone cheering and applauding)
- Also, we have a very
impressive audience.
Everyone's dressed up amazingly.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- So Margot, can you explain
the story of the movie?
- Well, Barbie Land is perfect
and the Barbies are having
perfect day after perfect day.
And everything's just wonderful
in Barbie Land unless, you're a Ken
or until you have an existential crisis,
which my Barbie does.
- What about the rest of you?
Who's your Barbie?
America, you can start.
- I'm not a Barbie, I mean, I am a Barbie
'cause we're all Barbies.
Unless you're a Ken,
then you're not a Barbie.
But, I'm a human in the movie, I think-
- Because there's Barbie.
- There's Barbie Land.
- Barbie Land, and then what?
- And in the last trailer
you kind of see the hint
of Barbie and Ken are headed
toward the real world.
And in the real world,
my character, Gloria, encounters Barbie
and it's a connection and
high jinks ensue from there.
And I think that's all
I'm allowed to say, right?
- And then, I don't
wanna spoil everything,
who's your Barbie?
Who do you play?
- Did you guys ever have a
Barbie like the one Barbie
that you designate as like her,
where you cut their
hair, burn their clothes
and draw on them?
That's the one I play.
(America laughing)
- Because let's face it,
we all had one (laughs).
You're like, "What if I colored her hair?
She needs a haircut."
I love your Barbie.
Can you do the splits
in real life or did they have to like?
- I can go to about there
and then, the whole system breaks down.
I can't do a split.
- Oh my God, way to go, then
the editing job is incredible.
- No, they did this whole technical thing
where my legs are always at a 180.
- Who's your Barbie, Issa?
- My Barbie is president of Barbie Land.
(everyone cheering and applauding)
- [Kelly] You're very funny.
- Thank you!
- Hysterical.
- Thank you, so much.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it was a treat
to be president somewhere.
(everyone laughing)
- What would you do if
you really were president,
funny or serious?
- Serious, healthcare for
sure, everywhere, university.
(audience applauding)
Funny, I would be more selfish,
I could just eat everywhere for free.
That would be my taxes.
Yeah, just walk in
anywhere, anybody's house.
If I like your cooking,
you have to cook me a meal.
- I'm president.
- Yeah, I'm president.
- I'm having dinner.
- Are you gonna feed me?
Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- Well America, and Margot,
Barbie is such an iconic toy.
So how does it feel, I don't know,
to bring her story to life?
I played with Barbies when
I was a kid, did y'all?
- Yes.
- I did not.
- You did not?
- I was not a Barbie player.
Were you guys Barbie?
- I was.
- It wasn't cool to, but
I still did, secretly.
(America chuckling)
- [Kelly] What'd you say?
- It wasn't cool to play with Barbies.
It was like at school
you'd be like, "Barbies?"
And then at home I'd be like...
(everyone laughing)
"You kiss," yeah.
- I don't remember having my own Barbies,
but my cousin had a box of them.
They were like all her Barbies.
We would cut the hair
and do all that stuff.
But I got the fold-out house one Christmas
when I was young and I was obsessed,
the Dreamhouse that folded out.
Honestly, coming into this movie,
that was such a priority, was the sets
and then getting to
see them be built right
in front of us
and they were just
huge, real life versions
of the Dreamhouse.
- It looks incredible.
- It was so amazing
and it's so beautiful.
- [Kelly] Our department says that.
- And it was like the first thing I said
to Greta you know, when
we first sat down, talked
about the movie,
I was like, "I'll follow your vision,
whatever you want this Barbie
movie to be, let's do that.
Except I just have one favor.
Please, please, please,
can we have a dream house
where she has a slide that goes
from her bedroom down to her pool?
'Cause that is my goal in life."
And she was like, "Yeah, sure."
- [Kelly] That's your thing?
- "That's your thing?" And I
was like, "Yes, that's it."
- Not like your character arc.
She probably thought you were
going big like ugh, okay.
- Or even the tone of
the movie, none of that.
I was just like, "I just
want that slide so bad."
- Oh my God, I think I'm
older than all of you.
So I loved...
I was obsessed with Barbies.
It was the cool thing
whenever I was a kid.
- But it's so different now-
- So you thought...
- Back then, I mean, to
be perfectly honest, one
of the reasons I didn't play
with Barbies, 'cause I
didn't feel reflected
in the world of Barbie, you know?
It was a very Americana version of beauty.
And, maybe there was one Black Barbie
and there were white Barbies
but now, it's totally different.
And to be invited,
to get to be a part of this narrative
where Barbie represents
so many more people, is
like it's the Barbie we deserve, you know?
It's so moving to get to be a part
of this re-imagining
of this world of beauty
and fun and aspiration where
more of us get to be seen.
- Absolutely, it's cool too
when you have kids,
'cause it's come back
around in such a big way.
My little girl, her friends,
they all have Barbies, they're obsessed.
Every time, she's like, "I
want the car, I want the Jeep."
I'm like, "Wait for a holiday."
Not Tuesday, you don't get it every day.
But anyway, it's really cool
though, to see her playing
and doing the same stuff that
I did whenever I was a kid.
But yeah, it's cool to see your kids.
I wonder if your kids will get into it,
but my daughter's really into Barbies.
And when I walk in, girl,
she's got 'em kissing
just like you just said.
I'm like, "What is Barbie and Ken doing?"
She's like, "They were kissing.
Mom, get out!"
(everyone laughing)
Did did you play with Barbies,
were you into Barbies?
- I was Barbie-curious,
there were Barbies.
- (laughs) You were Barbie adjacent?
- There were Barbies in the home,
my sister had a lot of Barbies and they,
they had diagnoses.
I mean, these Barbies were
messed up at her hand, you know.
But they were there and she spent hours
with her friends doing the most...
I mean, it was like her
training as a comedian
and a theater artist, she came up
with all these amazing things
and built an entire world out of them.
And I thought, "Wow, that's really cool.
You're really cool."
I love my sister, I'll say it here.
- [Kelly] I'll say it here right now.